all right I want to sort of just close
the loop on a couple of stories that
we've been talking about
um the CEO of my pillow Mike Lindell who
became a trump friend early during the
pandemic and said Trump was a gift from
God and we thought that's probably as
crazy as this guy's going to get and
then of course it got crazier and
crazier Mike Lindell who claims that he
has voting machines in his possession
that same Mike Lindell he is now sort of
reversing the burden of proof after
saying he is going to be able to prove
that the election was actually stolen by
Joe Biden now he's reversing it and
saying he will give you five million
dollars if you can prove to him that the
election wasn't stolen wasn't stolen by
Joe Biden which is of course a very very
different situation uh Business Insider
reporting Mike Lindell is offering five
million dollars to anyone who can
disprove his allegations of voter fraud
if they show up to his cyber Sim posium
he's going to be doing the Symposium in
August Mike Lindell a staunch Ally of
trump leading promoter of voter fraud
conspiracy theories says he'd give five
million dollars to anyone who can
disprove data that he claims shows
election interference but there's a
catch to be eligible you have to attend
his upcoming cyber symposium
which is taking place in South Dakota
between August 10 and 12. so there's 5
million available guys but you've got to
go to South Dakota and deal with Mike
Lindell and people who support him for
three days and the event isn't open to
the public according to an ad for the
event posted on lindell's website Frank
invitees include politicians cyber
Security Experts and the media
though it will also be streamed for 72
hours on Frank Lindell said he wants the
Symposium to be the most watched live
event in history and is aiming for a
billion people to watch via his website
I can't imagine a billion people are
going to watch this
um he has reserved 800 rooms but few
officials said they would attend there's
also a really there's a funny other
thing to this which is he wants media to
attend but like normal reporters they
can't take a free room from him they
need to reserve their own rooms to
maintain Independence and it's just
standard protocol so there's actually
reporters who have said in theory I
would go to this thing but because he
reserved all of the rooms I can't take a
free room for Mike Lindell because then
my reporting could potentially have been
influenced by the fact that I got a free
room I'd have to say I got a free room
Etc so he's almost shooting himself in
the foot okay here is um a clip where
Mike Lindell talks about the five
million dollars today I'm putting up
five million dollars to any attendee
that comes to this that's invited to the
Symposium if they can prove the data is
not the 2020 2020 election did you just
say five million did you just say five
million dollars
that's correct yeah so just you know the
concept of burden of proof it's shifting
from I have proof that something
happened to you proof to me that it
didn't happen as many of you know when
we've talked about burden of proof and
logical fallacies
um uh proving a negative can be very
very difficult and in fact many
conspiracy theories are based on the
fact that they put others in a position
of having to prove that X did not happen
uh whereas really if they are the ones
making the claim they should be able to
bring us evidence that X did happen one
other really funny thing and there's a
visual component here which if you're
not watching you're not you're not going
to fully appreciate
um there was this exclusive appearance
that Mike Lindell did I guess on his own
show
where he revealed the packet captures
which proved the election was stolen
what you're going to see is there it
looks like the matrix it's just long
numbers scrolling up the screen it's of
no meaning what whatsoever there's no
column headings take a look at this and
I'll describe it if you're just
listening today
yeah
yeah it's big news
once again that we're announcing put
those back put those the data back up
there again or let it roll again yeah
okay I really want everybody to know
that that this is you know that this is
what the Cyber guys
this is the real deal here everybody
this is first time well tonight we had a
show earlier but today what's the day
today Brandon today is uh July 22nd
Thursday July 22nd Thursday July 22nd
okay so all that's happening is numbers
are scrolling up the screen like crazy
and this is supposed to prove that Joe
Biden didn't really win the election and
as if we need to take this seriously but
some cyber security people looked at it
and again it's like you don't really
need cyber security people to look at it
but there's no column headings you can't
match these numbers to anything in
particular they're not evidence of voter
fraud of any kind never mind fraud that
suggests it was actually Donald Trump
who won even a single state that he lost
like it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever so anyway if you want to go
to South Dakota between August 10 and
12th
and I guess pay to go I don't know if
you have to pay to go or not
um to this symposium
and then you can prove that Joe Biden
won or that there wasn't fraud I guess
better said there's five million bucks
in it for you
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman